it's that time again to talk to you
about the latest games in new releases
and this week we get the web slinging
superhero swinging on all sorts of
platforms but not the xbox one not
everyone has a happy Parker goes up
against electro Green Goblin the
ruthless criminal Wilson aka kingpin
Fisk the deadly hunter Craven and the
sultry thief black cat save some for
spider-man 3 why doncha with great power
comes great responsibility start free
roaming Manhattan April 29th also this
week things get a little creepy with the
procedurally generated survival horror
daylight you play Sarah who's stuck
exploring an abandoned hospital
underground caverns some type of jail
and most likely any other creepy places
you can think of you don't get any
weapons just glow sticks flares and a
cell phone although you could debatably
take out a few people with those help
start exploring april twenty ninth child
tuck yourself in bed and let me tell a
story of Lemuria a long lost kingdom and
a girl born for glory now let's travel
to Lemuria which is missing its Sun Moon
and stars stolen by the black Queen
their tides are gonna be all messed up a
gorgeous RPG inspired by fairy tales
Studio Ghibli and yoshitaka amano
there's not much left to say here
besides you're not going to want to miss
this start recovering the celestial
bodies April thirtieth
this week we also get to travel to floor
awliya with kirby and the new fast food
inspired title oh yeah can I get a Kirby
triple deluxe with cheese new abilities
include beetles which allows Kirby to
use our rhinoceros beetles horn to
impale enemies and slam them on the
ground yeesh you also get circus which
allows Kirby derive in a giant rolling
vault of all over enemies juggle flaming
bowling pins to attack enemies above and
use exploding balloon animals as a
weapon Lord Kirby is not messing around
become hypernova Kirby may second and
while we're on this 3ds train let's get
into mario golf world tour play is one
of several confirmed playable characters
including mario luigi Donkey Kong Wario
Waluigi and the incredibly awkward on
the golf course Bowser he's got some
good follow-through them become a member
of Castle club in a second and lastly I
just want to mention jojo's bizarre
adventure all-star battle a ridiculous
fighting game that's anime as hell play
over 40 characters including your
favorites from the Joestar family like
Jonathan Joestar Johnny Joestar and most
importantly Joseph Joestar the only
character they have to have is do and
its massive steamroller badass for
further details visit gamespot's new
releases page release dates are based on
retailer listings and are subject to
change see you next week
you